can you actually linger on that a little
bit
i mean you mentioned minsky remember he
said
something in an interview where he said
the secret to his um like the way he
approached life was
to never be happy with anything he did
so there's a something powerful as a
motivator
to to uh doing exactly what you're
saying which is
everything you've achieved to see that
as easy and unimpressive
what do you do with that because clearly
that's a
i think useful thing i think i've kind
of matured past that
and i think the maturity past that is to
sort of accept
what it is and accept that
it has helped others build onto it
and therefore advance human knowledge so
it's very easy to sort of fall into the
trap of oh everything i've done is crap
what i told you last time is that i
always tell my students that our best
work is ahead of us
and i think that's more of my mindset
that's a beautiful way to put it
exactly what we've done is it's great
it's great for the time and it'll become
obsolete in 30 years
yeah not we can we are doing even better
we're doing it
exactly so basically our next work will
just
strive and and again you can't you can't
let the perfect be the enemy
of the good at some point you have to
rap i was having a
meeting with my student yesterday and it
was like
listen we know this is not perfect but
it's way better than anything that's
ever been done before
you know how to improve it but if you
try to
your paper is never going to get
published so
so it you know there's this balance of
we're already at the top of the field
get it out
yeah and then you work on the next
improvement and
in my experience this has never happened
we've never actually worked on the next
improvement
and that's okay
because you're basically putting a new
stepping stone that
others will be able to step on and
surpass you
my advisor in grad school would
basically tell me
and always let others write the second
paper in that field
just write the first one and move on
move on to the next field
you don't want to be writing the second
and the third and the fourth and the
fifth paper in the same field
just it's very
shocking to a student to hear that
because i was like i was at the top of
my game
i was owning that field and i published
the first paper i'm like
i'm ready for two and three and four
he's like move on just let it be
and i was like whoa and it's so
liberating
to sort of not have to surpass everyone
but just
just put your little stepping stone out
there
and others will step on it and put their
own stones further and eventually cross
a bigger river
than if you try to sort of make a giant
leap all at once
so you need both beautifully put
you